ديفيد ، أريد فقط إلقاء نظرة على
الوضع العسكري في الوقت الحالي ، فهذه هي
كل القوات الروسية التي
تحيط بأوكرانيا من ثلاث جهات والتي
كنا نتحدث عنها ، لكنك تقول إننا
يجب أن نركز بشكل خاص على
مجموعات الكتائب القتالية هذه.
وأين هم بشكل جيد ، فإن
مجموعات الكتيبة القتالية جون هي أكثر
المجموعات العسكرية القياسية المحترفة تدريباً لدى
الروس أنهم موجودون هنا في بيلاروسيا ،
وقد انتشروا الآن من
الحدود الروسية ، حيث قاموا
بمزيد من الأنشطة هنا في شبه جزيرة القرم
التي ضمتها روسيا بالطبع في عام 2014
ويبدو أنها تتخذ
مواقع أقرب وأقرب من
الحدود
إلى جانب صواريخ إسكندر التي تعد
صاروخًا متوسط المدى مما يث
ر مخاوف الأمريكيين الذين ين
رون إلى هذا وينظرون إلى صو
الأقمار الصناعية هذه التي قالها ال
وس  يمكن أن تبدأ هذا بوابل من الصواريخ
ثم تدخل